Charlie it's Oh Charlie yes so Charlie
is so cool so I haven't made a video in
three weeks I think you know what that
means
excuse time excuse time it's time for
excuse time I've got an excuse okay I
have actually tried to do two challenges
already but it didn't exactly go that
well the first challenge that I tried to
do was a rat I came up with some pretty
good lyrics you know it was it was
alright but it turns out I suck at
rapping I tried to record the rap right
but it looked and sounded absolutely
terrible
now you've been the kind people that you
are pretty sure that if I showed you
this video of me trying to rap you would
laugh your heads off which is good for
you but I do have a little bit of
self-respect right the only person that
is allowed to see this rap video is me
and possibly nerimon but that's it
alright maybe I'll try a rap sometime in
the future I don't know but for now I'm
gonna put rapping at the back of my mind
and the second challenge that I tried to
do was to eat an entire chocolate cake I
didn't do that badly
I've got about two-thirds of the way in
but the thing is the video turned out
really badly the sound was really odd
and it didn't really help with the fact
that I was feeling really really ill
when I was trying to talk so everything
I said was just like and
[Music]
and I really don't want to try any an
entire choco cake again just yet as much
as I love chocolate cake yeah it maybe
it made me feel really really really
really sick but today is different today
I am actually going to do one of my
challenges so I'm just gonna go now and
pick a challenge so I'll be right back
you've reached Jobs's charlie so cool
like how may I direct your call
hallo it's Charlie hey Charlie can I
help you something as a matter of fact
you can I was just wondering
Oh my challenge is ready yet they sure
are I'll send them over to you now
thanks babe take care alright awesome
back ok the challenge that I've decided
to do is to apply to become a knight the
challenge was submitted by this person
thank you the thing is you can't
actually apply to become a knight you
have to be selected but that's not gonna
stop me
they've given me an address for Gordon
Brown's house Gordon Brown is the prime
minister if you didn't know so I'm going
to write him a letter and apply to
become a knight here we go
okay I'm done
dear Gordon Brown my name is Charlie
McDonnell also known as Charlie is so
cool like across the internet and I am
writing to you today to apply to become
a knight I did not want to contact the
Queen personally about this matter as I
thought it would be hard to get through
to her
so I am sending you this message instead
in the hope that you will forward it to
her in due course I know that this
letter may sound a bit absurd but I do
have a number of points which will back
me up on this matter and hopefully
convince you that knighting me would be
a good move in your career I make videos
on the website YouTube and I'm currently
the 55th most subscribed user of all
time I've been making video blogs also
known as Lee logs and short comedy
pieces on the site for almost a year and
play a fairly large role in the YouTube
community examples of this include the
organizing of a YouTube gathering late
last year and I've also brought the
YouTube community together on a number
of occasions to help raise money for
charity I have noticed that the Queen
herself has her own YouTube channel and
also has a large amount of subscribers
but does not involve herself in the
community on the site a great deal I
believe that by making me a knight you
will be recognizing the YouTube
community as an important part of the
society and will be able to enforce a
good relationship with them as a side
note I would also like to point out that
I am not actually made of flesh and
blood but as a nerdfighter I am actually
made of Awesome I understand that only
the best of the best can become nice in
the first place and I think that the
fact that I am made of Awesome will fit
me into that category
and hopefully confirm to you that I have
what it takes thank you for reading this
and I look forward to hearing back from
you as soon as possible on this matter
you're sincerely Charlie McDonnell PS I
am like totally serious and they have it
that's my letter um it's late now so I'm
going to go and post that to Gordon
Brown in the morning if I hear anything
back I will be sure to tell you how it
goes and that's it for challenge Charlie
today I think I've decided I'm going to
spread out the challenges across 25
individual videos so you'll be seeing
those pop up as time goes along and
obviously I'm going to be making videos
in between challenge Charlie videos
talking about things and doing
maybe maybe doing normal vlogs how
I'll be a bit controversial so anyway
I'll see you later and I'm going to now
play you the outro to my videos did you
know my videos have an outro well you do
now
[Music]